okay they're fun let's do this
it'll kill the ultimate forged in fire
match-up you are the forest and fire
Champion two Champion plays in a deadly
weapon Showdown it will kill 20 blades
20 Champions you decide the winner
forged in fire Madness
a pair of Frankish throwing axes my name
is Nick Overton I am 22 years old there
is a scouting program through my church
and I had a camp out one summer and they
had a blacksmith shop I made my first
snap there and it's been a Snowball
Effect ever since and now the same shop
that they taught me in is now partly my
shot and I get to teach the scouts there
as well
the Frank is throwing X was the deadly
and iconic weapon of Germanic tribes
known as the Franks during the third
Century Masters of shock and awe combat
the Franks carried multiple axes in
battle and would throw them at close
range to break formation and cause chaos
the ax is heavy blade and razor sharp
edge cut deep into enemy flesh and was
capable of damaging armor and crushing
bone the axes brutality in the hands of
the Franks are still prevalent in movies
and can be seen in the 2010 film
Centurion
the chakra my name is Christopher
Farrell being a professional placement
you don't make a lot of money winning
this competition will make the next year
of operation costs a lot easier to
shoulder
the shock room is an Indian throwing
weapon which dates back hundreds of
years Weir seeks would throw it like a
frisbee or spin it at high speeds on
their fingers before launching it into
the enemy weapon of the Hindu god Vishnu
its exotic Nature has resulted in it
appearing in TV and movies odd jobs
lethal bowler hat in the James Bond
movie Goldfinger was a variation of the
weapon as was Xena's weapon of choice in
the cult TV series The indian warriors
would wear multiple shock rooms into
battle carrying them around their arms
their necks and even stacked high on
their heads in specially designed
turbines
So the plan today is I'm going to take
some 1018 mild steel we're going to
start by drilling two holes go in with a
drift chisel it out start forming our
eye on both of these
that looks like a good eye right there
it's time to really profile this thing
so I'm taking it to the power hammer
that way they move a whole lot easier
I have the profile forged out have the
eyes drifted
my forged welding went good I believe
they're good enough for heat treat
and I feel like the heat treat process
went really well so next two days I can
focus on fit and finish these access
right now that are assembled then I'm
going to do some finer detail work
so they're both at the finish that I
want no I need to go above and beyond
that's what my mom would have wanted me
to do this was a challenge and I'm
really proud that I pulled it off
my intern
my internship of a traditional chakra
will involve doing some things that I
don't really do in my shop
anything in my shop to accommodate this
shape most people probably have a jig
set up so that they could pull this
around a lot easier I don't have a jig
so I've been doing a combination of
rounding it on the Horn of the Anvil and
using the bevel to Hell ground it
further
[Music]
pretty close I'm done with the initial
shaping
the only issues that I think I may run
into is Forge welding the seam of the
shock room because it might get burned
the heat is very inconsistent it's very
difficult to control precisely where
you're heating up in the charcoal Forge
you're kidding me right
you're burned got too hot somewhere else
not hot enough where the oil needed to
happen so I'm going to cut out the
sections of the shock room that were
ruined and weld on a new section and
being a guy who works mostly with hand
tools I want to see if I can pull it off
it'll work out or it won't
[Music]
well it ain't perfect but
all right Blade's fist well frankly
you're a Frankish throwing excess look
fantastic but are they lethal well to
find that out I will take your weapons
and deliver some well hellish of a blow
on this ballistics dummy all right Nick
it's your turn right there fun let's do
this
thank you
[Music]
all right Nick upon impact
crushes the face easily in the head your
edges they dig in with every chop and
slash little Keel thanks good job
Chris you're up next excellent
[Music]
wow what really opened them up in the
belly here so he's totally disemboweled
definitely cut through all the way and
broke a rib
it'll kill
welcome to the strength test
I will be throwing your Frankish
throwing axes into this large wall
Nick you're up you ready for this let's
do this
[Music]
well Nick your edges held up great I
can't even tell that they've been
throwing handles show no damage nice job
for the strength test we're going to
take your chakroms and see if it was
designed well as a throwing weapon we're
going to use a specially designed
mechanical device that will launch your
weapon into the sugar canes if your
weapon can cut cleanly through a sugar
cane that would indicate that you have a
weapon that would do mass destruction in
the field of battle
this device here is calibrated so that
every throw is going to be the same for
each of your designs Chris are you ready
yes sir
in three two one engage
well Chris
it cut two sugar canes
I see no indentations on the edges here
this will cost maximum damage in the
battlefield
good job
okay thank you now it's your turn which
weapon will you choose forged in fire
Madness